Quý vị và các đồng chi ở đây đang có mặt và nhà dành để có một người
phật của 2 hạt quan trên phục biển tên 5 của tuc quốc.
Và ngày hôm nay thì tôi muốn với thiệu với phật người của các thang ra của khán bộ
trên sĩ như thế, và phía tính ra của bà trong vình sau để xem là bố đội ở đây
trong những lại tông gì.
Mặc dù trong khi khu khăn rất là nhỏ, nhưng mà thật sự chỉ chục được.
rất là nhiều các phía lại sọc.
Thế thì đồng chi cũng thể kể qua một số những lại sọng mình được trong đây.
Các lại sọc đất rất là cái như ra này, chỉ có không bố một tới lâu cài.
Câu bố đất.
Câu má, râu lăng.
Câu lăng.
Câu lời râu thơm.
Thế đội chi có chán nguyên gì để được vào.
Được ăn.
Cái nơi ra, thì mọi người thạm ra,
tình báo thì chúng tôi,
tình có nguyên.
Nguyên, tình theo, ra, bịt.
Hương cảnh, tình gà, để nguyên hảo cả bịt.
Câu lên là lời sọc,
của một đôi là phía tình thạm vào.
Câu bí vị và các đội chi,
vật qua khó khăn tửa thách,
vối sực cạnh của chiều hó, cùng như in cách lạng sáng thảo.
Tung tắt tăng ra, chẳng đôi trên ra ràng,
để cà một người đã đã được hiểu kết quả tích lực,
vó phần cả tiện lời sống bộ đổi.
Được các bộ, chiến sĩ trên tâm tung tắt,
hoàn thành sất sách, giềm buộc được ra.